no one knows how we came to this land a
land
filled with magic and danger that's my
father
king of dumb bro then there's my
brothers we Devils more like a bears my
mother she's in charge of every single
day of my life
a lady rises early does this stuff are
dope does not please her weapons on the
tape ah mom she just doesn't listen
pretend I'm Merida speak to me I don't
want to get married I want to stay
single and let my hair flow in the wind
as I right through the Glen firing
arrows into the sunset places everyone
each of the best thorn was compete for
the hand of the fair maiden oh that's
attractive sure little decorum beast
Jedi give us a turn I can't be cautious
it's perfect
I'll be shootin for my own hands
Christmas
don't you dare loose another arrow
what became of this precious daughter I
once knew
I want a spell that changes my fate dan
what's the worst that can happen
where's the qui les filles war
let's get you loose again blue body
Piscotty
so much if you had the chance to change
your feet would you
you